bad ass hacks for surviving the holidays
you want to be the best toast ever and
that's cool but you are broke and now I
have all of these people coming to my
party and I've already spent all of my
money on presents yeah this may not be
the best time to ask but you owe me 20
bucks from lunch I have no memory of
that you can still be a star with DIY
smartphone speakers a fresh take on
Christmas trees and an impromptu
Christmas chandelier this is a great
party you must spend a fortune on this
you like tradition but tradition doesn't
have to be boring grandma can I offer
you a drink
I know you like martinis but you know
maybe you should try something new no a
regular martinis fine you can't teach an
old dog new tricks spice up an old
favorite with the pumpkin spice martini
the dogs got a hell oh you're exhausted
you've been watching your sister's kids
all day you'd like to treat yourself to
a well-deserved berry sangria but hot
lava there's hot lava oh yeah entertain
them with fun and easy holiday craft
projects like snow slime an elf Donuts
sir tonight forever I know the floor
Stella grandma is going to get a lot of
gift cards this year I just love this
wrapping paper I hate to tear it I just
wish I had somewhere to put all the skip
cards being the badass that you are
you've got grandma covered with an
awesome DIY gift card wallet
I've got your cover grandma oh did you
make this yourself guilty oh you are my
favorite great child yeah I found it
laminated all of your old journal
entries yeah I know Oh